let's talk talk show for a second now
you're in this game
of ratings and talk show who who is the
enemy let's
let me let me beat you up there you have
enemies of course she does she's got
other television shows that are on
against her i don't want to hear any
hippie [ __ ] you're gonna
[ __ ] kill me howard i swear to god i
called kelly clarkson
i wanted to be on her show i wanted her
to be on mine
i'm syndicated so i'm
freelancing baby
i want this show to work but not at the
expense of anyone else
and if i learned one thing growing up in
hollywood is you don't
[ __ ] step on anyone else's head to
get where you're going
because when that head is gone you're
gonna fall right [ __ ] down
what happened when you called kelly
clarkson did she say no listen she said
listen
no she's great networks they want to
protect you know
the the status quo
it was a little difficult i'm not
kidding
you're like well you know i will say
this
i want this show to work there are
people here
that have a that we all have a job and
it's a dog eat dog world and i want us
to [ __ ] have a
job i know how important this is and i'm
going to fight
every fiber of my being so that we can
go to work
every day but drew step on heads out
there
you personally you you almost have
listen
i'm gonna do whatever i can to make this
work because this
for this point in my life for the sake
of my family
right this is the best job i could ever
have
and i will do every fiber in my being
not to [ __ ] this up and let me not
[ __ ] it up i mean
make it work yes i love this job
i wish you success on the talk show
you've entered a very competitive
arena i will talk to you off the air
about who your enemies are and who they
are
you just need a little help for that